are you together strangers on a train
but I bet I can tell you why she's
travelling you see this one very strong
line here that is your heart line and
that is deep there's a break in the
middle is that why she looks so sad
I think that's probably just her resting
face but the big news is that she meets
the guy again soon so that's lovely for
her why did you text me did you break up
with somebody do you hate your job no
please don't [ __ ] me that your life
is so brilliantly perfect because if it
was you wouldn't have texted run and you
wouldn't be sitting on the strange you
texted one back
tell me you want me right now you could
tell me no I don't want talking
I've been totally honest with you
has anyone totally honest
[Music]
do you want to be here with me or is
this about something else are you in
trouble we have a feeling like we're
walking away from sins and we can never
walk away from I'm not the same person
they used to be
[Music]
hello could you take us to the nearest
station you help me get this badger in
the van I'll give you guys a ride I
don't want to run don't say that unless
you mean it
you